Google Glasses people Google if you're
using your cell phone to text and tweet
and make calls that's that's old-school
already glasses we're all gonna be
wearing this pair of $1,500 glasses that
is going to record everything you do and
you're gonna be texting from your
glasses and watching videos and
uploading them and downloading them
Google put out a video let's take a look
okay glass record a video
okay glass hang out with the Flying Club
Google photos of Tiger heads
you ready you ready right there okay
glass take a picture
all right so this wonderful video you're
gonna wear these glasses suddenly you'll
want to jump out of a plane and do all
kinds of stuff that you normally
wouldn't do but I really truly believe
this is going to be the worst thing ever
we are good are privacy the little bit
of privacy that we have left is going to
suddenly disappear because everyone you
talk to is going to be recording you at
all times
desi what do you think well actually
when I first read about this the first
thing that popped into my mind is that
that would violate California wiretap
law you are not allowed to videotape
people without their consent and then
post I mean that's the whole thing about
the James O'Keefe hopes videos of the
Acorn you know there was a settlement
that that acorn worker got because James
well he wasn't criminally prosecuted he
got immunity to give up the unedited
tapes but that's against the law
don't you think that Google just because
of their money and influence will
somehow they're gonna say it's not video
taping it's you know digitally you'll
probably try to get away with it in some
fashion that's not like they don't have
lawyers to do that or lobbyists but you
know it's not alan against the law in
all states you know that's specifically
what's against the law in california is
that you must have explicit permission
to do so and to post it so that would be
an interesting legal issue about that
the the other part about that that
really gets to me is that the google
spokesman and the link that you sent to
me she said that behaviors and social
norms will develop over time i have that
quote here i'm glad you read it okay i'm
incredible i think this is incredible
that google is saying we're gonna put
out something that is gonna so shift the
way we all act and the way we all behave
that you're just gonna have to join us
for the ride and and you have no choice
and we'll clean up the mess later yeah
now HL you're the only one here with
glasses so i feel like you're the expert
here so take it away let's talk to
privacy real quick i i i don't mind the
idea of somebody taping me not because i
have liked attention but because i feel
like that's where we're going that's not
that they're now they're not commenting
on well they might be commenting on me i
don't know we live in that world now the
world is changing just like when people
were fearing to what telephones would do
or what electricity would do this is a
part of that that we shouldn't just be
fighting it should be
acknowledging it definitely setting up
laws that protect people like the
California law but we should be
acknowledging that changes are happening
and then working that into the system
where we feel comfortable in our
democracy I don't think we should just
be saying no to it but I will say the
quote that you read about Google it's
also the owner of the bar said I'm a
thought leader someone that's a weird
question yeah so that's someone calls
let's get to that so we jumped ahead
here so there is a bar and where is he
in Seattle where the the bar owner has
already said even though this stuff
isn't even on the market it's not even
coming out to the end of the year the
owner of the bar has said our bar you
know our patrons are here for privacy
not to be recorded we're banning this
this thing that doesn't even exist we're
preemptively banning it everyone's into
preemption these days Adam do you want
these glasses what are you gonna do with
me no I'm usually wearing beer goggles
anyway but yeah but there's a part of I
mean then I was thinking that like my
mind goes to like all right now my
girlfriend's been trying to see if I'm
cheating on her you know if I had a
friend wear them to like spy on people
you know and then but and then you know
there's a whole thing of like okay let's
say you go to a bar and you hook up with
a chick who's not attractive because
you're drunk
you couldn't photoshop her the next day
in your head you know oh she was the
hottest girl but now with these glasses
there's no Photoshop and you're actually
gonna see how ugly the person think of
what I was doing my research is
incredible what do you think does any of
this stuff make us happier now look I
say this as an addicted tweeter I love
Twitter I'm on it all day but does any
of this make us happier or actually
connect us more we think it all connects
us there's a difference you're you're on
Twitter because your job is to be a
social commentator and you want your own
TV show and this is your job to get fans
and that's how you want to spread to the
masses you have a reason to be on
Twitter okay there are people on Twitter
all day I'm eating a sandwich you know
look it's nice out I'm going to bed I
mean and those are people who should not
be on Twitter because I mean not to be a
judge but it's like come on I mean
they're just avoiding everything is
there is a whole level of like I don't
care what like go on an Instagram do
Instagram I'm looking at people
food why do I want to see your lunch I
think it's a part I agree that people
shouldn't be tweeting about their food
I'm definitely against that but I do
think that and this is from a personal
experience but when I was diagnosed with
cancer there's a conversation happening
with people online who are tweeting
about their food then see something like
I'm tweeting about my own situation and
then they're able to connect in a way
that is so far beyond it just being my
job as a writer comedian it's like
they're connecting with people and
they're on a different level
stay with him okay it's a serious thing
but there are people all day long who
are like you and that's it that's all
they have that freedom to do that versus
quality you know it's not really our
place to judge that they have the rights
to do that you just don't have to look
at it think about this idea that is is
any of this connecting us more
ultimately whether the people are just
putting out food pictures or they're
saying something really deep and
profound I mean is it actually
connecting us or are we now all going
out to eat and sitting at our phone the
whole time taking pictures of our phone
and we forget who we're talking to yes
and yes actually I think it does connect
us more but it does tend to connect us
to people who are more like-minded and
keeps us in our little silos where we
don't actually interact with other
people so much you know it does keep us
connected with those people you know
keeps me connected with my family I love
that but you know when you get into
these silos you know this is how we get
into the Fox News brain where we have
all these people who studies show you
know know so little about actual facts
in proportion to how much they watch Fox
News right and they're just reinforcing
the same right so you know it can't help
it can also hurt you know it's it's sort
of a two-way street what interests me
more about the Google glass issue is
just the privacy I mean I know we've
given up so much of our privacy already
that people don't know what's happened
but over in the European Union they have
much stronger controls over privacy and
your content and your
and how companies can use that we don't
have those protections here so I think
that this is this I'm glad we're talking
about it but I don't know that we'll be
able to talk about it before abuses
begin I'm being selfish okay there's a
comedian if I'm wearing on stage and I
can look at people's people's faces are
sometimes hilarious they get offended or
they're booing or they're laughing -
then go look what I'm looking at I think
that's pretty cool and net in that
regard but but then there's also like
but when they're all sitting there
wearing the glasses staring at you when
tweeting out every bad joke that's it
but I've been to some cool like orgy
type parties that like that you know
that's those would be kind of cool to
have like I mean that's okay I have a
pretty cool life sometimes there are
time and I just think my shepherd
watches bonobos comm is the official
outfitter of the Rueben report get this
shirt used code TRR t0f adobo calm